Listen to me carefully. Hit the green button.
It can be a little sticky.
I need everyone to help us have access.
It's a party.
Okay. What do you know?
Let's assume I don't know much,
but I'm a fast learner and I'm a God.
Well, let's start at the beginning.
Here we go.
So it's now
or never.
There's something you have to see.
Welcome back, everyone.
It's Charlie.
This will be my Loki.
Season two Episode six Finale Trailer Video.
We only have one episode left
and it does look like Loki is evolving.
Like he's upgrading himself into the god of stories.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
you guys talked about doing Loki Season three.
But for the most part,
they did say that there was a definitive ending
that answers a lot of questions
about the future of Jonathan Majors.
Is Kang like how they're going to deal with that?
Going into Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty end,
even though Kevin Feige didn't answer definitively
whether or not they were doing Loki Season three,
he did say that it would be possible,
but a lot of it just has to do
with the audience response
to Loki Season two in general,
which seems like it's been pretty positive.
But like the way he talked about the ending for season
two is it won't be like season one
which ends on a huge cliffhanger of him
seeing the statue of Kang without them explaining it
we're still doing that giveaway for the Loki Blu rays
all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber
and post all your predictions for the fanatic.
How are they going to end things?
But. Talking
more about Loki becoming the God of stories.
This is a very big comic book concept.
At the end of episode five, Loki learned
to control his time slipping in, talked about changing
the story, basically gained the ability to travel
through time naturally, like a huge power upgrade.
so he ends the episode purposefully traveling back
to the moment in time right before the timeline blew up
in the TVA control room here so that they could try
things differently, like basically replay the events
that happened before this and try things differently
so that the timeline would not blow up.
I think that's actually a big misdirect.
And one of the big concepts of the episode
is the idea that they don't need the sacred timeline,
the way they've been thinking about it before.
Like the Loom is like this cage
that's been controlling the sacred timeline.
And I think that they've actually
been thinking about this wrong the entire time.
Loki's been talking about wanting to preserve the TVA,
like basically
keeping things status quo,
like we need to control these other branch timelines.
There are a couple of them that exist right now.
when in reality,
I think they'll find a way to allow the wider
multiverse to exist, like the whole concept of the loom
won't actually matter.
At the end of the episode.
like they'll realize, we don't need the loom.
Like this doesn't have to actually exist in order
for the TVA to continue existing and doing what
they want it to do. Being a positive force for good.
so that's going to be one of the big
turns in the episode.
Like early prediction is they find out, Wait, no,
we've been thinking about this wrong the entire time.
We don't actually need the loom itself.
but Loki can basically now do what all the Kangs do.
Like the Council of Kangs, every variant of Kang can do
controlling time without the need for technology.
So yes, he is like way, way more powerful.
But I think in the MCU,
they sort of rein this in a little bit like he's
not the god of all reality,
like he can change the timelines, so to speak,
but only on a smaller scale end, For the most part,
he can only jump around in his own timeline.
So it's probably the way that Marvel
is using to keep him from getting too overpowered.
Because otherwise he would very literally be
the God of all reality.
Maybe he'll boast about that the next time he sees Thor
when they do their eventual reunion.
Like, guess what?
I'm the God of all reality Now isn't that special?
But here's the thing.
In the trailer, there's actually this green effect
of traveling through the timeline.
I think this is meant to show Loki's perspective,
traveling through his own timeline,
like what it actually looks like
when he's time slipping on purpose.
And that's what the green lines are like Loki's magic.
But they look like the timelines
as you're traveling through them.
this also kind of looks like one of the promos
they released, which is Loki in this garb,
which is basically like a representation of Loki
as the God of storage.
So that's why a lot of people are like,
he's probably turning into the god of stories.
they've also based a lot of inspiration
for the Loki characters in season
one and season two on God of Stories.
Loki from the comics.
Now the comics are obviously a little bit different
and they're just borrowing some inspiration
from those For instance, Sylvie's horns
look just like his horns.
But originally in the comics.
The way that Loki became the God of swords.
Like he transformed from the God of lies
into the God of stories because he unlocked
some secret abilities
that he didn't know about inside himself.
and that's kind of what
we've been seeing on the TV show so far.
During the comics, he goes with Thor and travels
to these cosmic halls of the unknowing and reads
from the book of Loki,
which is basically like a cosmic tome
that contains everything he'd ever done, everything
he will do, basically his entire timeline,
spelling out his entire life like this is what you're
destined to do, kind of like when he watch
the highlight reel of the 616 Loki like his entire life
that they had on tape that Loki strikes up a bargain
with the cosmic house of Ideas,
which was a big marvel comic book Easter Egg.
In real life.
In real life, Marvel's Use, the slogan
The House of Ideas.
For years, like Stan Lee used to talk about it
way back in the day,
there's a version of that in the Marvel Universe.
Loki travels there and speaks with the cosmic beings
who actually write the books, like the Book of Loki,
basically scripting his entire life,
saying how things will go, what he's destined to do
and strikes up a bargain with them to change his story,
quote unquote, making it better like he wants
to do more positive things so he strikes a bargain
with them to add pages to his book,
basically adding a bunch of adventures,
completely changing what he's destined to become
in his part of the bargain he makes with them,
he agrees to eventually die like the hero, quote
unquote, is destined to die
it's kind of like Loki traveling to Marvel comic books
in real life and talking to the writers like,
Hey, could you actually change the story?
Which is a trope that they've used
in some other people's comics.
it's almost like Loki breaking the fifth wall, like
he realizes that he's a fictional character in a story.
In the past, the writer who changed the story,
they kind of did a version of this
during the end of the She-Hulk series, where she talked
to like the robot version of Kevin Feige,
like she travels to actual Marvel Studios,
breaking the fourth wall in the fifth wall.
Loki kind of did a version
of this inside the Marvel Universe,
but when he leaves, they did wipe his mind.
So he forgot that he was able to even change his story.
later he winds up telling other characters lies
about a similar type of story
where he was able to actually change his own reality,
His own timeline, change his story, so to speak.
and through the telling of the lie,
he begins to actually remember the truth
of what he actually did visiting these being sort
of unlocking those memories inside him,
in also unlocking the ability to change his own time,
like change his own story at will.
Basically.
in that was how he evolved
into becoming the God of stories, like being able
to change his own timeline, so to speak.
like I said, though,
I think that they're changing this, like kind of
powering this a little bit,
like reining it in for the MCU
so that he doesn't get to like
he can only change things about his own life.
He can't change the lives
like the reality of every single other character,
But I think they're doing this
before Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty,
just because it'll make Loki a much bigger asset.
Like he'll be able to jump around in his own timeline
during Kang Dynasty
in It'll help them in their battles post
all your theories about this in the comments below.
Like Loki becoming the God of stories,
being able to travel around
inside his own timeline,
change things about his own life
in how they use that to their advantage
in the future of the Marvel Universe.
there's a bunch of new footage from episode six.
Like I said, it's mostly them
replaying the events of previous episodes,
like when Loki is talking to Obi about being a God.
Like, you might not understand
everything that you're telling me here.
Looking at this old
Back to the Future model of the TVA.
But I am a fast learner and I am a god.
Just more jokes about him being a God,
then telling Victor timely which buttons to hit.
Like they're basically retrying things and he doesn't
turn to spaghetti this time, it sounds like.
but there are a couple of moments where he does
turn to spaghetti.
So maybe Loki actually jumps around in his own timeline
a couple times in the episode,
like he went back at the beginning of the episode.
So like, we get to try things again,
but maybe they also muck it up again
and he has to travel back to this point again,
like, okay, well let's try this a couple more times.
like how many times are we going to watch Victor
Timely turn into spaghetti here?
in that it seems like at some point he walks out
on this platform without a spacesuit himself.
early theory is that this is actually from
one of the last scenes in the season in
is after they sort of realize what's really going on
with the loom and how they're going to fix things.
And it's completely different
from what they've been thinking before.
like I said, I think the idea is that
they ultimately will realize that they don't need
the loom to exist in order for the TVA
to continue existing, for reality, to continue existing
And I think this sort of plays into
he who remains like ultimate ideas.
We haven't really gotten into this
in a couple of episodes,
like there was a teaser for him at the beginning
of episode four, like he has this grand plan
in seemingly his accounted for his own death
like he knew that it was going to happen
that'll probably influence the events of episode six
Miss Minutes
seems like she actually knew what that plan was
and she will be coming back during the episode.
So we'll see about that.
There's also that whole side plot with her
wanting a body.
I don't know if they're going to have time to pay
that off.
The episode will be a little bit longer than normal
episodes, though, post all year, he
who remains theories in the comments too, like
how do you think that he's going to try and influence
this actual story?
Like, I think it has something to do with the concept
that the loom itself.
Like the loom is his way of controlling everything,
and he wants to maintain that even though he's
seemingly died.
there's still a lot of questions like we're mostly
talking about Loki becoming the God of stories
and being able to travel around in his own timeline,
basically like the most powerful version of Loki
that we've ever seen.
but that's really just like part of the episode.
Separately, there were a bunch of reports
in the past week about Marvel pivoting
when they get to Avengers six secret wars
and using like a different concept for a main villain
during that maybe eventually actually
doing a version of God Emperor Doom.
did a separate video about this a little while ago.
Some of the stuff in the report
got into like the Blade movie.
There have been some people trying to debunk
some of that stuff, but some of it is still true.
for the most part, I believe Marvel's path forward
is that they're still using
the council of kangs is like a big concept
during Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty.
None of that stuff has changed
That's basically the counsel of Kangs
versus the current main version of the Avengers.
The roster for the new Avengers
might cycle just a little bit,
but we're supposed to get some teasers for that
by Captain America for We'll probably
see the new version, the Fantastic Four, maybe
a couple of the new mutant characters during that.
Like obviously Deadpool
three is meant to set up Avengers six Secret Wars,
but I'd be surprised if he isn't involved in some way
with Avengers five.
the original version of the Secret Wars
movie was going to be
sort of a combination of the original secret wars
from the 1980s.
In the more modern version there was going to be
a multiverse version of the Avengers team
that would fight beyond her character, but that beyond
her would have been like another variant of Kang.
Then I think Marvel got cold feet,
like Jonathan Majors had all this legal trouble and
and the WASP Quantumania underperformed.
So there is a number of reasons
why Marvel was like, maybe we should do something
a little bit different for Secret Wars.
Maybe we will actually do a version of Doctor Doom
as the main villain.
that movie isn't going to come out
until at least like 2027.
It could get delayed even more.
So I wouldn't worry too much about that right now.
But but supposedly at the end of Loki season two,
Marvel will answer a lot of those questions.
Maybe not in a definitive the price.
There'll be a lot of questions, But at least
they'll answer some of the major questions.
Like are you still going to continue
keeping Jonathan Majors as versions of Kang?
but there's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
My full Loki finale video
we'll post later this week after they release it.
we started doing the Invincible season two episodes.
I'll post links with those in the description below
and we just got the Echo trailer,
Marvel's first rated R series.
it's going to be big Daredevil Kingpin series, too.
So it definitely feels like they're trying to make it
like the classic Daredevil Netflix series,
like the classic Marvel Netflix defenders
series in general, they're also releasing like a brand
new brand called Marvel Spotlight for those types
of grounded, hard core, mature, rated shows.
The producers were also using Ghost Rider to explain
some of the concepts behind Marvel Spotlight.
see it.
Imagine that a lot of the shows that they release under
that will feel kind of like the classic Marvel
Netflix shows.
everyone click here for that brand new echo trailer
video and click here for all my Loki episode videos.
Thank you so much for watching, everyone.
Stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!